[Aplausos]
quiere simplemente existir o quieres
vivir una vida remarcable que deje
huella no era la típica persona que se
la pasaba quejando de todo los problemas
de mi país los problemas del mundo me
deprimía cuando leía las noticias y lo
peor de todo es que me enojaba cuando
veía que nadie hacía nada al respecto
siempre dando mis ideas en redes
sociales con mis amigas con mi familia
esperando a que un político o el
gobierno en turno la llevara a cabo pero
un día me hice la pregunta y qué hago yo
para cambiar esa realidad que no me
gusta en mi país y cómo le hago yo para
transformar esta rabia que tengo en el
cuerpo en energía positiva y
transformadora para el mundo
estas preguntas no tenían respuesta
y me di cuenta que si quería ver un
cambio en el mundo lo tenía que hacer yo
misma
y encontré en el emprendimiento una
forma de cambiar al mundo pero les
quiero platicar que un día me enamoré me
enamoré por completo cain redonditas
conocí un modelo de negocio increíble
que se llama empresa social en donde
entran en juego dos temas la filantropía
y las utilidades y entre más utilidades
generes más impacto realizas
a mí toda la vida me encanta de ayudar
pero me he dado cuenta que cuando lo
único que haces es dar dar dar enseñas a
las personas a recibir pero no los
enseñas a generar por eso me enamoro
tanto este modelo de negocio
ya sabía que quería ser emprendedora
social pero ahora viene lo bueno como le
hago
hice una lista de los problemas que le
veía al país y posibles soluciones al
mismo cuando al fin encontré una
solución que era realizable escalable
que no implicaba vender un riñón
hipotecar algo salirme de la escuela me
fui con todo el problema que elegí
fue el comercio injusto desgraciadamente
en nuestro país hay muchísimas
industrias que tienen este problema pero
cuando estaba viendo esto está tomando
una tacita de café y me hizo clic el
comercio injusto en el café y decidí
hacer un startup que tiene como
finalidad empoderar a los pequeños
productores cafetaleros y darles un
precio justo por su trabajo
muchísimas personas cuando les dices que
eres emprendedor te dicen ay qué padre
eres tu propio jefe no tienes horario y
te puedes ir en tenis a trabajar y en
cierto sentido sí pero nunca te explican
el trasfondo de lo que es ser
emprendedor no te dicen las friegas que
te llevas no te dicen que familias
dependen de ti así es que en mi camino
yo he aprendido muchísimo me he caído
como no tienen ideas la he regado
muchísimas veces y de estas enseñanzas
tengo 10 lecciones que hoy les quiero
compartir a ustedes
primera lección no te enganches con los
números a mí me pasaba al inicio que
decían no es que solamente estoy
llegando un pequeño productor no estoy
haciendo un cambio tengo que llegar a
más tengo que llegar a millones pero una
persona muy sabia me dijo con el hecho
de cambiar una sola vida ya estás
cambiando una historia y con cambiar una
historia ya estás cambiando el mundo así
es que si si logras cambiar una vida te
estás poniendo tu granito de arena para
cambiar al mundo
según la elección que esté es una de las
que más trabajo me ha costado aprender y
que más me ha dolido piensa global y
actúa local un día está en facebook
aprovechando el tiempo y de repente vi
un post que me hizo me llamó la atención
era un niño sentado flaquito con unos
ojos grandes grandes grandes y una
mirada que transmitía una tristeza
no les puedo ni explicar
esta foto tenía un título ven a ser tu
voluntariado con nosotros y venían una
serie de preguntas que yo en mi mente
empecé a responder sí sí sí tal parecía
que este anuncio estaba hecho para mí
soy dije guau o sea con esto voy a
cambiar al mundo no yo estoy
emocionadísima está rayado empecé a
llenar los formularios checar vuelos
porque pues está un poquito lejos ya
solo me falta un pequeño detalle el
permiso pero dije bueno eso se resuelve
ya mi papá de trabajar y le dije oye
país que fíjate que un niño me necesita
son cinco semanas me das permiso porfa
nunca se me olvida lo que mi papá me
respondió me dijo y por qué te tienes
que ir tan lejos si a 15 minutos de tu
casa hay gente que te necesita
yo todavía ilusamente en este momento le
respondí
pero era verdad al día siguiente decidir
al lugar que mi papá me dijo y a 15
minutos de mi burbuja perfecta en donde
podía prender y apagar la luz tomar agua
potable echarle agua al baño había gente
que no tenía esto y lo que más me había
dolido era que estas personas siempre
habían estado ahí pero era yo la que
había decidido no verlas
así es que no nos tenemos que ir muy
lejos para cambiar al mundo
hay que generar soluciones locales
soluciones de nuestro entorno a
problemas que entendemos y así si
nuestra idea es lo suficientemente buena
y escalable va a haber otro grupo de
chavos en la india nigeria en donde se
les ocurra para poder implementarla así
es que hay que pensar global y actuar
local
tercera elección se autodidacta yo soy
abogada de profesión y lo único que
sabía de café es que los abogados
tomamos muchísimo pero hasta ahí y
hubiera sido tan sencillo decir ay no es
que yo no estudié eso ahí no es que yo
no entiendo eso poner mil excusas más
pero estamos viviendo en la era de la
tecnología de la información
tenemos bibliotecas en nuestros
bolsillos imagínense lo que hubiera dado
nuestro abuelito por hacer un trabajo
con google
hay que aprovechar la tecnología y hay
que aprender día a día
cuando ya tenía toda esta idea estudiada
aprendida ya sabía lo que quería hacer
le platiqué a dos de mis mejores amigas
esta locura les encantó y esto llega la
cuarta lección rodéate de gente buena
gente que tenga la misma pasión que tú
la misma misión que tú gente honesta
gente que quiera cambiar al mundo y
también gente positiva porque les juro
que si son emprendedores van a tener
momentos difíciles en su vida y
necesitas a gente positiva a tu lado
cuando llevamos con todo con nuestro
estar todo iba perfecto padrísimo
increíble un día chocamos chocamos
contra una barrera que no les voy a
explicar el tamaño está gigantesca y
muchos de ustedes conocen ese nombre una
palabra cinco letras miedo cuya y pero
qué tal que no funciona allí pero qué
tal que a nadie le gusta mucho pero qué
tal que es un fracaso que haces miedo
miedo miedo miedo cómo le haces para no
tener miedo al fracaso
no se puede siempre vamos a tener miedo
el chiste es pasar esa barrera del miedo
pero un día que ya está a punto de
decirle a mis amigas soy ansa en que
estuvo increíble este sueño que padre
persona que hasta aquí vi un post en
facebook que creo que se aprovechó el
tiempo no te lleves tus sueños a la
tumba por el miedo a que puedan fracasar
qué tal que el mundo necesita de tu
sueño ah caray sí es cierto que tal que
es un éxito qué tal que a la gente le
encanta qué tal que revolucionó la forma
de tomar café en mi país
y estoy me lleva a la quinta lección
pierde el miedo al fracaso es mejor
fracasar porque no funcionó a fracasar
porque tuviste miedo a atreverte
y agárrense porque iba a llegar un grupo
de gente a su vida los haters que la
real academia española los define como
lo dicho de una persona que no había
agua oye yo no creo que vaya a funcionar
oye y cuando te vas a buscar un trabajo
de verdad oye y que no quieres ser mamá
este último era súper cotidiano y yo no
lograba entender por qué la vida de una
mujer no se puede compaginar con ser
empresaria y tener una familia pero
bueno eso es tema de otro texto que hoy
no vamos a tratar y de verdad que tú
está harto es como tu bebé es como se
agarran y te dicen oye tu hijo está
horrible
sin testigos tienes que ser súper fuerte
para resistir a los ataques de los
haters y esto me lleva a la sexta
lección elige tus propias batallas
escucha los haters analiza lo que te
dicen decide si te aporta quédatelo y si
no te lo aporta nada desecha lo
séptima lección define tu motor muchas
personas me preguntan oye mariana y por
qué café oye y por qué estás ahí sin ni
siquiera está para vivir oye qué te
motiva y yo lo que pienso
son ellos ellos son el motor de esta
startup cada vez que hay un problema un
bache cualquier cosa no sé cómo no sé
cuando no sé ni por dónde lo voy a
resolver pero se resuelve por ellos
porque ellos son el porqué de esta
startup si me caigo me vuelve a levantar
y si me caigo me vuelvo a levantar todo
porque ellos son el motor y esta es una
de las cosas más importantes si se van a
lanzar a emprender tengan un motivo
octava lección que estaba muy de la mano
con todas las caídas que van a tener se
constante
mi papá toda la vida me ha dicho quieres
lograr algo hazte amigo de constancia
quieres correr un maratón sé constante
quieres acabar tu carrera sé constante
para todo en la vida tienes que ser
constante porque nada en la vida es
fácil nada se nos va a dar del cielo
si quieres lograr tus sueños tienes que
trabajar por él tienes que darle diario
día y noche tienes que llorar tienes que
sudar
si quieres lograr tus sueños hay que
trabajar y ya sé que esto está súper
trillado pero de verdad hagan lo que
aman yo creo que no hay nada más triste
que estar en un trabajo que no te gusta
que sabes que eres fácilmente
reemplazable que sabes que no estás
generando un cambio acuérdense la
pregunta que les hice en un inicio
quiere simplemente existir o quieres
vivir una vida remarcable que deje
huella
novena lección cree en ti créeme el
poder de tus sueños piensa en grande
olvida esos pensamientos suicidas de ahí
no es que yo estoy muy chiquito ay no es
que todavía esté inventado es que no
puedo como lo hizo diez besos para crear
amazon o como lo hizo steve jobs para
crear a paul creyeron en sus sueños
cree que en ti radica la semilla que
dará esperanza un mejor país porque así
es
y décima lección todos podemos cambiar
al mundo en nuestro propio entorno de
nuestra propia área de especialidad
si eres cantante no solamente cantes
canciones canta himnos quieres ser no
solamente cocines pasteles crea momentos
si eres arquitecto no solamente
construyes casas crea ligados
si eres maestro por amor de dios no
solamente enseñes álgebra inspira y
empodera tus alumnos para crear cosas
grandes
si eres empresario no solamente generes
dinero genera impacto porque nunca eres
demasiado joven demasiado viejo o
demasiado normal para cambiar al mundo
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]